some of the fine folks at the GameSpot
office have been hard at work creating
Super Mario maker to stages here are
some of our favorites that have been
built so far our first stage title three
thwomps three doors comes from Tony
Wilson in this stage you'll have to
defeat all three giant whomps in order
to complete the course but beware the
stage requires a bit of puzzle solving
and precise platforming Curtin Davina
likes nice things so he decided to make
a nice stage titled nice town this stage
isn't too strenuous but it does have its
fair share of Secrets
keep your eyes peeled as you explore
this course you might just find a couple
hidden areas despite being called simple
course 101 Lily Zaldivar as Mario maker
courses anything but simple it's short
but demanding you'll need to be fast and
precise if you want to make it to the
end clock's ticking
another great course by Tony Wilson is a
very bad zoo its theme of animal
exhibits and beating the zookeeper to
escape works really well against the
challenging puzzles that are present a
little advice there are no checkpoints
and only one super mushroom so try your
best not to get hit Shawn Booker's
winter nightmare is probably the
toughest stage on this list after 30 or
so tries I decided to let Shawn himself
clear the stage for me he'll need to be
fast responsive and patient if you want
to finish this one Kevin cadets of XP
switch panic might be my favorite stage
on this list using p-switches scattered
around the course you'll need to keep
the ground under Mario's feet solid if
you're too slow the bricks will turn
into coins and you'll fall through the
stage last but not least Cali play geese
catfish two ways drops you in the middle
of a piranha plant infested jungle there
are two ways to complete this stage you
can take the underwater path or stay on
solid ground but be careful no matter
which way you go there will be a ton of
Piranha Plants between you and the
flagpole those are some of the stages
we've made so far all of the course IDs
for these stages are in the description
and if you have any stages you want to
share with us leave them in the comments
below
[Music]